adrian what's going on i have a sister
who was diagnosed with diabetes when she
was two years old
and now she's 31 um
has two kids is in kidney failure
um she is
with the same blood type and basically
i'm
i'm just i go back and forth on whether
or not
i i want to go through with the process
of trying to give her one of my kidneys
oh man okay so you've been confirmed
that you can be a donor huh so
walk me through your thought process
well
um you know at a young age my family was
told she was told that
she she couldn't have kids she shouldn't
have kids it would
significantly impact the uh just the
her life expectancy and it could be
problematic for the children as well
um and two kids later i mean that's
exactly where we are
um she's just i just struggle with it
because she's somebody who hasn't really
taken care of herself the best that she
could
and my concerns are you know if if i
if i do this is is it something that
she's gonna be willing to do for the
rest of her life
is actually take care of herself and and
and do the things that's going to be
necessary for the rest of her life in
order to
to you know maximize what's going on
as long as you know the impacts that it
has on my life you know it's um
i married myself and i'm
we're working on having kids and you
know
having just uh the whole dynamic of
everything it just it makes me go back
and forth
and on top of that i'm just i'm getting
now i'm getting pressure from my my
mother of course and
hey so so listen brother don't
don't don't punish your sister don't use
your sister's
behavior to weigh in on your decision
here
and i know that might sound
counter-intuitive um
but man getting getting diagnosed as a
young kid with a
with a challenging medical condition
that you got to manage and deal with
that level of trauma and the concern and
stress that everyone has around you it's
not an excuse but it's a context for a
tough life for a little kid
what i don't want you to get into a a
either or
like i'll give it to you but you're
gonna have to man you are gonna make
yourself
insane you're gonna sever that
relationship whatever is left of it
and you're gonna go nuts this is a
decision for you
not for her and i know that sounds crazy
to sound because she lives
if you give her a kidney right
but it sounds like in your head if i'm
reading the tea leaves here
you almost can't not you're that kind of
guy is that right
correct there you go and so it's almost
not
whether it can't be about whether she's
worth it
she's your sister of course she's worth
it right and you can come up with all
sorts of reasons why you don't want to
why it's scary why it's frustrating why
it's terrifying all those things man
and they're all real but the question is
like if you can step up and help right
now are you going to are you not going
to
yes that's what i'm asking are you going
to do it are you not going to because i
think you already know the answer bro
yeah um i mean i
i feel like i don't have a choice so yes
i i guess
will you do me a favor though i think
you're right i think you don't have a
choice
but i think the temptation is going to
be to blame that lack of choice on your
sister
it's going to be to blame that on your
mom and i want you to take
ownership of it because that's the
caliber of person that you are
similar to if i was walking home tonight
and there's a little kid playing in the
road and a car is coming
i can't not move that kid out of the way
i can blame the driver i can blame the
kid but the reality is you know
i should blame my dad because he raised
me to take care of the little children
in my neighborhood
he raised me to step into hard
situations and that's where you found
yourself
and so when it comes to having kids man
i think the way to think about it is do
you want to
be the dad of kids and they know
oh yeah you know the ends of earth's the
ends of the earth my dad will go for you
he gave his kidneys to his sister he
literally gave a body part to somebody
that he didn't even have a great
relationship with
that's the kind of man my dad is
versus is it going to impact some stuff
i'm sure it will
i don't i don't know enough about organ
donation um
and the aftermath but i'm confident it
will impact things here and there
but it sounds like you're the caliber of
guy that's gonna step up and do this
and tell me if i'm wrong man if you're
not then man you've heard me say a
million times on the show tell your
parents no forget you guys you don't get
a vote you're out
sister you don't get a vote i'm taking
my other kidney i'm going home
you're free to do that man it's your
body
but i hear that character hesitation in
your heart because i think you know what
you're gonna do
am i right sure yeah
so what's your hesitancy
just uh i mean unfortunately if
financial you know i it's it requires
the money that's going to take me to a
different state
um i'll be out of work you know i've
just in in the past year i you know just
with the craziness i've been laid off
twice
um we're just now getting into a
position where
we're starting to climb out of a big
hole um with that
um and it's just uh
i mean as much as i don't want to admit
you know money is
is part of my decision because i
you know i have a wife that's relying on
me i you know i
i have responsibilities um
and it's it's all being taken into
consideration
hey it's hey it should okay it
absolutely should be taken into
consideration
and don't feel bad about putting the
nuts and bolts on this thing it's cool
to be all courageous and yeah here i
come to save the day but man you're
exactly right there's a financial toll
to pay you're going to be out of work
um you may have just picked up a third
job you're in a tough tough economy in
anchorage right now
right and that's when you may have to
swallow some pride and get on the phone
and call some folks to help you out
and that may be asking your mom and dad
to help out or if you've got other
brothers and sisters to help out
and there may be nobody there man there
may be nobody to answer that call
and
i don't want to make it sound like it's
going to be easy i'm trying to put
myself in your situation right now i
have an older sister too and if she
hollered at me and said honey a kidney
you mean you know what i would be i
would know i was going to do it
you know what i would be scared to death
i'd be scared to death that it didn't
work i'd be scared that i only got one
left
i'd be scared that i've got two little
kids that i want to make sure i can run
around with
and i want you to know um it's okay to
be scared
to death that you're gonna undergo a
pretty serious surgery to remove
part of your body right it's not a minor
thing
and you're going to do it at a character
you're going to do it out of
the deepest love there is for other
people have you talked to your sister
how does that conversation go man
uh we haven't spoken in years
so let's start there will you start
there
adrian will you call your sister today
and just tell her hey i love you i love
you and i heard you're hurting
and tell me what's going on
yeah because i think that's the place to
start
is connect your heart back to your
sisters and she may tell you
screw you adrian i want your stupid body
part and maybe you're all the way off
the hook dude
probably not um but i want you to go
first
having characters hard man doing the
right thing is so hard
and oh man
love comes with so much risk and so much
pain and so much
what if what if man and then here we are
and then you have says james talked to
in years
but i have a feeling man if someone that
you worked with you'd be that guy that
stepped up and if it was
your brother-in-law you'd step up and if
it was somebody at your church you'd
step up i think you're that guy man
um and if you're not hear me say
it's your body you feel free to do what
you want to do
but i don't want you to backtrack and
say well i'm not going to because
in the past she fell in the blank or my
mom is really making me no
man the heat of this decision
rests in your heart and in your
character do this because you got to do
this because it's the right thing to do
do it because it's
hard hard and you're that kind of guy do
it because
when you have two or three or four
knucklehead little kids running around
your sister is going to be back in your
life and she's going to tell them you
know what your daddy did for me
and that's the kind of man he is man
that's that's that's a story you tell
your kids right
that leads me to this i've got um
here's this is that yeah this is it
um so
you've heard me talk a lot about this
and usually i talk
about it again making jokes about it
about hey
it's hard to have hard conversations and
it's hard to make wills it's hard
because everyone's faced with hard
conversations
and everybody passes away and i was
thinking over the weekend
i got to stop making jokes about that
sometimes it's hard
right i come from a family we talk about
death all the time in passing that's not
normal it's probably not even healthy
but life is full of hard conversations
and these really harsh
realities and if we're loving our family
we're gonna talk about
hard things like hey man i would love
to help out here we haven't talked in
years we've been estranged from one
another you don't take care of yourself
help me help you right that's a hard
conversation hey mom
i know you love your daughter and i
love her too and i'm working on it but
how about you
back off a little bit um hey honey i
love you and we have three little kids
but one day we're gonna pass away and
we gotta have a will we've gotta do this
stuff because it's gonna happen this
all under this umbrella of how to have
hard conversations
if you will text legacy to 33789
that's legacy to 33789
we're going to talk it's just um it's
something here that the ramsey folks
created about how to have hard
conversations how to talk about
making a will how to talk about these
hard conversations that you
and your wife need to have and if you're
not even married yet how you and your
future partner can have these
conversations but
man we've just done it three times on
this show hard conversation after hard
conversation after heart conversation
that's the life that we live in
um and the better we can get at having
those hard conversations being honest
with one another
not the easier life's gonna be but man
it just begins to pull away these bricks
of weight so we can handle these things
with light feet
on a firm foundation so um adrian man
we'll be thinking about you here's the
deal adrian
i'm i'm asking am i gonna beg i got
close just then
i wanna know how this conversation goes
with your sister and i wanna know what
you decide shoot me an email back and
i'm going to read it out over the show
or we may call you back because i'd love
to know how that conversation goes and
what you ultimately decide